luke here with the outdoor boys youtube
channel today we're going to show you
how to make bread on a campfire we're
going to show you lots of different
techniques we're going to show you lots
of different recipes it's going to be
easier than you think and tastes real
good all right let's get to it
warning this video is not keto friendly
not many people think of bread as a
camping food but it is a fabulous
camping food its ingredients are
non-perishable and super light this
small bag of dry ingredients is enough
to make a large loaf of bread and a big
meal for me now i know a lot of you out
there are intimidated by making bread
bread making can be complicated but it
can also be extremely basic so let me
give you the most basic recipe to get
you started bread flour sugar salt yeast
and water
now first you pour some bread flour into
a bowl make a little hole in the middle
and fill that hole with a little bit of
yeast a pinch of sugar and a little dash
of salt around the edge fill that hole
with warm water mix it with your finger
and give it about five minutes or until
it looks all frothy and bubbly mix that
all up and keep adding a little bit of
water at a time until you get a nice
sticky dough that you can still form
into a ball you want it sticky enough
that it sticks to your fingers in the
counter but dry enough that it can
actually be formed into a ball pound
stretch and roll that dough until it
starts to set up and get stretchy it'll
dry up and no longer stick to your
fingers or the counter and you'll be
able to stretch it apart and see through
it it's called window painting if you
can stretch it enough that you can see
light through it then you've needed it
enough
once that's done cover it and let it sit
for one hour or until it's doubled in
size then you know it's ready to bake
you can use it immediately or you can
stick it in the fridge and save it to
take it camping or use it another day 10
hours later you can see it's doubled in
size in the fridge if the dough gets
warm or you leave it in the fridge for
more than three days it'll just slowly
become sourdough starter and you can use
it just like you would any other
sourdough starter you can make sourdough
pancakes you can add flour and water to
it to make a sourdough bread
it's great
now i've needed a mixed dough out in the
field plenty of times but if you want
some shortcuts here's one you can add
water and all your ingredients to a
plastic bag and knead it in the bag it
makes life a lot easier a lot less mess
once the dough is set up a little bit
you can pull it out of the bag and
finish kneading it by hand or you can
combine all the ingredients together
stir it once or twice by hand and chuck
it into a bag and let it sit for eight
to ten hours and it will combine mix
thoroughly and the yeast will get
activated all by itself you can do this
in the field or do it the night before
you leave on your camp out and have
dough ready to go the next morning
all right i brought some doughs that i
made yesterday
this is the one i just added all the
ingredients together and let it mix in
the bag and this is the one i spent all
the time needing and they're really
really similar
look at that look at the nice stretch
that's developed overnight looking good
hey jacob hey babe
jacob
look i've got jacob
and becca with me alright guys now i'm
gonna show you how to cook bread over
fire using a stick
feel the heat of the fire with your hand
and the spot where you can hold your
hand for just about the count of three
but no longer that's about 375 degrees
that's where you want to be cooking your
bread take a glob of bread not too much
roll it into a snake
skewer one part of the snake way down
here
and then
wrap it around
the end
and skewer it on the end like that you
want to be able to see a little bit of
the stick poking through between the
wraps just like that
just kind of keep it in a slow heat and
just keep rotating it every once in a
while
let it cook thoroughly becca's just
painting jacob's playing in the water
i'm baking bread this is a lovely day
all right this is this is looking pretty
done let's take it over here
you guys gonna help me eat some bread
absolutely this is the sweet cinnamon
butter from texas roadhouse it comes
with their rolls
is it too hot we're gonna put some of
this sweet cinnamon butter all over this
do i just bite over it go bite into it
it's like corn on the cob
is that like the most delicious bread
you've ever tasted
i'll tell you the worst bread recipe
tastes better fresh than the best bread
recipe tastes cold
nothing beats fresh hot bread now if you
guys don't want to make your own bread
from scratch you can do the same trick
with the pre-made doughs and i like to
use the pre-made cinnamon rolls just
unwind the cinnamon rolls wrap them
around the stick and then use the
frosting in the can and it's just
it's a really great breakfast snack when
you're camping all right we're gonna
cook some bread in the dutch oven i'm
gonna make biscuits with sharp cheddar
cheese inside it's gonna be good got a
block of sharp cheddar here
we're gonna take a little bit of cheddar
i'm gonna fold that up in there
seven little dough balls with a block of
cheddar cheese inside
[Music]
you want to preheat your dutch oven but
you want to make sure the temperature
isn't too high sprinkle a little bit of
flour in the dutch oven and if the flour
smokes it's too hot
yeah that's too hot we're gonna let that
cool down a little bit
so we just peek at it every five minutes
or so to make sure they're not browning
up too quickly
oh those are looking good
what do you think of that
they look and smell good
oh
is the cheese all melted yeah it's so
good it's perfect there you go fresh
water biscuits with melted cheddar
cheese inside crunchy on the outside
gooey and cheesy in the middle
that's good
i gotta stop eating i i'm gonna fill up
too fast i got a lot of stuff to film
flatbreads are hands down the easiest
breads to cook over a campfire and
there's lots of different ways you can
do it if you guys watch my channel
you've seen me do a lot of survival
camping and winter camping and often
i'll use the back of my avalanche shovel
in the winter time to cook flatbreads
it's a great trick and works really well
but if you have a large smooth rock or a
flat rock you can also use that and it
works perfectly well but i got a little
cast iron skillet here so i'm gonna do a
fun flatbread recipe i'm gonna make
navajo tacos
i got a little corn oil here but you can
also use canola peanut vegetable
whatever we're just gonna grab some
bread dough
and spread it out into a disk do it like
you're making a tiny pizza rise and moon
hits your eye there we go nice bit of
flat bread all right let's test our oil
and see if it's hot enough nope not yet
we got our disk of bread here we're
gonna
put it right in there
now if you want to pull these out of the
skillet and smother them in honey butter
and fried bacon it is one of the most
amazing breakfast ever
taco seasoning
oh that smells good
get
there we go navajo taco thank you this
looks so good what do you think do you
like that so
if you really want to show off you can
make campfire pizza and you don't need a
dutch oven to do it you can use this
same dough recipe and just sandwich it
between two shallow cookie sheets using
a pair of c-clamps just put some coals
top and bottom on there and bam you have
the most amazing campfire pizza so
delicious okay that's a good crust i'm
proud of that if you're in the woods and
you want to bake a proper loaf of bread
and you don't have any utensils or
cooking gear at all you can build a
stone bread oven then go and build a
roaring fire in there and let it burn
for like 20-30 minutes at least get all
those rocks nice and hot do a nice stiff
dough that'll hold a ball shape and let
it bake for about 15 minutes or until
it's nice and golden brown
that will make you a delicious chewy
crunchy crust loaf of bread it's
absolutely delicious one of the most
primitive simple ways to cook a loaf of
bread is to cook it in the gray fire ash
get yourself a nice stiff dough and roll
it into a ball and bury that dough make
sure there's hot coals all around it and
let it bake for about 15 minutes
and then just pull it out dust it off
and it's good to eat don't worry about
the fire ash it won't hurt you it's
completely sanitary and it tastes just
like flour by the way you can also cook
steaks just by laying them on the coals
works really well the skulls will stick
to the steak when you first put it on
but once the steak is done the coals
fall right off if you want to make
awesome campfire donuts just take this
dough
roll it into rings deep fry it in some
peanut oil and then roll it around in
some powdered sugar as soon as you pull
it out of the oil eat it hot and it is
absolutely amazing this is something
we've made a couple times on camp outs
and it's great another great way to cook
bread over at open fire is to steam it
and so i'm gonna take some of this dough
and i'm gonna make some sweet pork
steamed buns so i've got this little
doohickey right here and it's a steamer
tray
i got some shredded pork here
i cooked this slowly for about eight
hours in a bunch of root beer and spices
so it's really sweet take a nice big
glob of that
all right we'll just let that steam for
about 15 minutes
see it's just like a normal bun in the
middle
oh all this little pork goodness came
out no it's actually pretty good
steaming is a great way to cook a lot of
things over an open fire you can cook
muffins brownies bread pudding
cakes you can buy those just add water
muffin mixes in the store
put some of it into a metal cup
put a flat rock in the bottom of your
pot and just rest that cup on top of the
rock so it's not on the bottom
put the lid on and just let it steam
it's a great way to cook muffins using
equipment you've already got know
another way to cook bread is to boil it
we're going to make some dumplings well
if you ever got a can of soup and you
want to make it a little bit more hearty
add some dumplings to it
just a little extra water in there
all right we'll just get that boiling
you know you guys might not know this
but my wife has actually got a little
website where you can buy her paintings
i'll put a link in the video description
below
thank you
all right once your soup's boiling
take little chunks of dough
just like that
just drop them in there
once you got the dumplings in there just
let it boil for about four or five
minutes and you're ready to eat
nice hearty bowl of chicken noodle soup
with bunch of bread dumplings in it
there you go your soup's gone from
something that'll barely whet your
appetite to a hearty meal
all with the same bread dough becca did
you enjoy that food i loved it all
good if you guys want to see more
campfire cooking videos we've got a ton
of them i'll put a link in the video
description below and if you guys want
to see our camping trips we have over 70
camping trips in our camping adventure
playlist check it out we put out new
videos every saturday morning so don't
forget to click subscribe thanks for
watching if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button you'll
get notifications thanks for watching
[Music]